bonjour est elle un jour c'est patrick
patrick bruel savoir s'il était possible
de réserver une table pour ce soir
peut-être surtout écoute et kif
tu vas fermer les yeux tu veux rester
les yeux ouverts je suis en mesure
d'ouvrir un moment et je vois où je suis
je me dis si on y est
[Musique]
ça fait dix ans dans marié foot us aucun
sert lucho canon donc ils sont aux
cadeaux au pied nommé s'était moqué
botero d'immeubles et la réunion qui
arrive bien pleine d'accord c'est
beaucoup mieux que ce soit lyon au piano
c'est toi au piano est bonne ce qui est
truc je vois encore isolées des
incitations aux consommateurs le choix
sur la scène avec un micro je crois que
j'en vois un peu non ballack on est
certes loin des 6 c'est pour ces moments
de bonheur de joie et de fous rires
ça fait du tort
que vous êtes présents
dans votre cas alors c'est votre vie
dans votre canapé sans jamais nous ap
depuis les débuts
vous m'avez soutenu
personne ne pensait qu'on pourrait le
faire réparer
disons des ondées
[Musique]
on sait jamais lâché mais les beautés
je ne sais plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut détacher l'europe ne pensait ne
jamais le petit truc
le vice du rohan c'était sa région
notons d'ailleurs le vrai pour une fois
de plus et donc tenir au frais j'invite
tout si c'est possible c'est bien qu'ils
aient une espèce de petit phrase et
rythmiques genre pour faire une chanson
facile facile d'abord des paroles soient
suivies d'un poêle à bois faut d'abord
des paroles débit débile une petite
mélodie qui voyait des retards c'est
qu'ils te prendre la tête et une colline
pour bien faire la fête dans celle là on
se rassemble à 5 à 6 ou sachets tu le
sens comment ça tu veux le faire hyper
parodique genre lyrique sérieux frein
sérieux alors à ça alors là il faut que
tu sois vraiment comme ça avec des
grandes consomme tout comme l'argent
comme ça pour faire une chance soit
fermé voilà charles dumont qui ont
aiguisé juin dès mon jeune ami trop
fraîche je sens au facile
facile aux fraudeurs des vols des mileux
les villes mais j'y crois
et les graphiques pour bien faire voilà
fait dans ces deux là
en sera sans à charge
tu es
[Musique]
la chanteuse a dit loeb ça arrive à
quelle sauce elles au fond de cette
lointaine chance de sa vie d'autrui les
armagnacais serrer les rangs de cette
boîte curie mais je l'avais mis dans la
boucle est ma patrie que tu vois c'est
quoi j'aurais fait reconnu qu'il y avait
un talent qui s'appelle un restaurant je
suis passé et il je sais pas si cet opus
[Musique]
bonjour est un bon jour c'est patrick
patrick bauwen savoir s'il était
possible de réserver une table pour ce
soir peut-être c'est vrai sur le bras
que j'avais était venu avec qui adorent
le chef exactement pensera ce serait
pour ce soir véritable sera peut-être
aussi 5 6 ou peut-être sept ou huit
je ne sais pas vous n'avez peut-être
peut-être 10 sa réalise
je vais je peux vous confirmer dans une
demi heure à telle heure ou peut-être
raté leurs 15 ou 30 45 22 heures merci
[Musique]
patrick merci merci merci
10 bon bah voilà